voici le chef de famille c'est guillaume
aille à la chorégraphie aujourd'hui
[Musique]
mais la jeune fille part toujours à
l'heure
sur les masques nous nous sommes trompés
ni plus ni moins le mea culpa d'olivier
véran dans un livre qui sort aujourd'hui
dans par delà les vagues l'actuel
porte-parole du gouvernement et ancien
ministre de la santé revient sur sa
gestion de la crise du coc vide il
affirme qu'il n'a jamais cherché au
début a caché la pénurie de masques
il confie également avoir été soumis à
un stress permanent lors de la première
vague en 2020 et avoir touché du doigt
le burn out
allô maman bobo
jérémiades un raid des jérémiades super
le burn out qui explose dans le monde du
travail l'épuisement professionnel
représente désormais le deuxième motif
d'arrêt maladie derrière le qu'ovide ils
représentent 20% du total et pour la
première fois ces maladies
psychologiques dépasse les troubles
musculo-squelettiques selon un baromètre
annuel il est 7 heures exactement on
retrouve anne claire coudray pour le
journal houasnia royal
secondes mais j'ai un doute moi je
savais déjà qu'on était dans une france
d'assister maintenant je vois qu on our
nous sommes dans une france de fragile
donc je ne suis pas surprise par rapport
à ça moi ce que je vois aussi c'est que
moi par yoshi professions libérales je
suis un peu hypocondriaque aussi
d'ailleurs hier j'ai touché une fois je
suis allé faire un task ovide direct
c'est à dire voilà et pour non mais
c'est vrai moi par exemple je suis une
fois tesco bin hammam à la pharmacie le
dit pourquoi vous venez autant jeter bas
jeu dès que je touche je viens
c'est rime avec trouillard ça au sahara
c'est bon
moi vaillant professions libérales ça ne
me viendrait pas à l'esprit d'être
malade parce que même si je suis malade
j'ai rien qui tombe je suis pas payé
donc il ne faut surtout pas que je sois
malade donc même si je bon il se trouve
que je suis jamais malade en fait on est
malade parce qu on est non on est mal à
ça ce qu'on veut glander chez soi et
avoir la paye qui tombe voilà pourquoi
on est malade parce qu'un rhume c'est un
rhume une angine et on va pas bosser
mais c'est quoi ces gens qu'ils foutent
rien c'est quoi ces glandes us et
assister ces feignasses tu te sens tu
m'énerves pas si tu lis faut que ça
aille vite parce que si je vais pas vite
personne va vite mais ça c'est ce que tu
crois mais tu vas lui décide de faire un
call pour me calmer comme si l' on avait
le temps
on va on va faire un anniversaire mais
les invités arrivent g7 et des paroles
balorre la
halle mes confrères professions
libérales ne sont officiellement jamais
malade c'est à dire que je les vois en
audience franchement dire moi c'est
pourquoi non tu me laisses parler
parfois ils sont vraiment pas bien ils
sont à l'agonie je les vois les chats
mais ils viennent quand même alors que
quand ils ont la paye qui tourne dans
une bonne idée parce que s'ils doivent
plaider ensuite la veille le bon ils le
font pourquoi parce qu'ils aiment leur
travail parce que c'est parce que c'est
pas des faibles là c'est un truc de
c'est quoi ces fragiles là c'est quoi
ces faibles et la fin dit quoi votre dos
que total blanc
là je sens direct de bordés ce pays
retourne dans son
histoire de l'art elle est mon débat va
errer tourner j'espère que vous y voir
tout à l'heure pour ma petite piqûre
jeune infirmière aussi prôné une
permission de sortie alors je sais qu'il
est un peu tôt samuel mais je vais vous
proposer avec vous et tous les
téléspectateurs d'aller boire une bonne
bière du côté de l'ombre avec notre
correspondante alors vous allez me dire
oui c'est trop tôt mais en fait les pubs
sont en danger ils ont de grosses
difficultés financières et risquent de
mettre la clé sous la porte à cause de
la flambée des prix de l'énergie on en
parle à 7h10 sont que nous avons changé
de monde
ouais moi des fois je suis un petit peu
tête en l'air désolé on te dis là j'ai
plus de batterie
c'est pas grave manu
aussi sa décharge qu'être monde et bein
il devrait faire des décharges infinie
voilà où ça capte l'électricité dans
l'air ça le met directement dans la
tablette n'est pas le problème un
scooter un sac isotherme et un gilet
identique ben la flèche le surnom que
lui donnait ses clients ressembler à
tous les livreurs de la société des
livres mais à l'intérieur du sac aucune
pizza ou autres plats cuisinés plutôt de
la poudre blanche de la cocaïne l'homme
pouvait livrer jusqu'à 30 clients par
jour je vous jure les mecs vous fasciner
j'aimerais bien je rentrais dans ma tête
pour savoir comment serait géantes sont
qui a vu l'eau dans notre cerveau à la
chouette c'est more more more more more
grâce à un informateur les policiers se
sont intéressés à cet individu ils ont
alors entamé un travail de filatures et
découvert un étrange comportement c'est
qu'il arrive à enchaîner un nombre de
livraisons très importante sans jamais
passer par un point de restauration pour
prendre un repas qui devait livrer la
tempête dont vous nous parler de ce dont
on parle là et donc vous voyez autant là
dans la partie jaune qui est autour de
l'ouragan on a des choses qui sont un
petit peu un petit peu violente mais
quand ça va arriver sur la péninsule
ibérique autant vous dire que ça
ressemblera plus à rien ce sera repris
dans une perturbation et c'est quand
même daniel qui aura une influence sur
le temps que nous aurons à partir de la
semaine prochaine aujourd'hui bon c'est
vrai que souvent ménard varient on peut
le dire comme ça
mais là on les voit une gosse qui te
fait les poches j'ai envie de lui en
coller une de tonnes
laurie c'est vrai vous avez parfois été
avec marine le pen par bp bon vous avez
les billets mais je vous le reproche
qu'on estime à wray way
temps déjà francs capitaux qui m'appelle
président oui mon franck voulait être
mais il voulait faire michael
sabia bahreïn est mort